let's talk about the crisis uh with the
opposition now talking about ukraine of
course and joining us is shadow minister
for policing sergeants hi ms jones
thanks for joining us on the programme
this morning how concerned is labour
this morning about what's happening on
the ukraine russia border
well i don't think you can um
underestimate how serious the situation
is
over 130 000 troops gathered
in belarus and in russia on the border
with ukraine i don't think we've seen an
amassing on that scale
for decades
so
it's a really difficult time we support
the government's attempts to use
diplomacy and use all uh the armory that
they have in terms of economic and uh
diplomatic
responses to work
with our allies really important with
our nato allies with our european union
allies and with all our allies across
the world to sort of try and come
together
to use as much power as we can to
persuade the russians not to act but as
you know this is a very
serious time the prime minister will be
will be uh
talking to his european colleagues um
this week
we know the americans have been talking
we know that everybody is doing all that
they can
we do think that we need to move much
faster in terms of
russian money in london and make sure we
are acting um on that and we do need to
look at
how much we rely on russia across the
european union in terms of energy and
other things but this is a very serious
time we stand with the government on the
attempts that they are making to ensure
that this doesn't escalate further
talk to me about your brief as well if
you would um how happy are you to see
cressida dick go
well we needed to see reform i wouldn't
say i'm happy she's given decades of
service uh to the um police
service um
but there were a lot of issues that were
raised from the murder of um
sarah everard uh bieber henry nicole
smallman we had a series of inquiries
that really did question um the
metropolitan police in terms of
institutional corruption
and then last week in terms of misogyny
and sexism and racism that we saw in a
really horrific report and i think the
mayor of london needed to be assured
that action was going to be taken um and
that change was going to be made and in
the end he lost confidence in in crested
dick's ability to be that change the
question now is this goes beyond the met
this is a wider issue of policing
culture and of course it comes on the
back of years of cuts
of low prosecution rates and rising
crime so there is a big program of
reform that we want to see the home
secretary lead in terms of
training for police um in terms of uh
what happens in in misconduct cases um
and in terms of vetting to get into the
police force in terms of their use of
social media
and we need to look at all of these
issues so that we make sure the police
is our police services that is the best
that it can be which is what all good
police officers want to see
talk to me about the prime minister he's
on his leveling up tour this week we're
told he's up in scotland he's going to
the northwest of england as well dining
street parties not even in his rear view
mirror anymore isn't it time to just
move on
well he has to fill in um his um form
that he's been sent by the metropolitan
police this week
there are many cases of parties that
look like they were breaking the rules
um and that is very serious if he misled
parliament um then he has a duty um to
come and address parliament and
and and to resign if that's if that
turns out to be the case his leveling up
agenda is words um and not action we
need proper investment in our towns in
our coastal towns in our industrial
towns across the country we need to see
um investment in
infrastructure we need to look at
business rates so that all those you
know entrepreneurial businesses that
want to set up in our towns that can't
because they're
stuck paying huge amounts of business
rates are given some relief there is a
whole raft of activities that we need to
see that this prime minister has not
done and going around the country and
talking about leveling up is not going
to do it for people who need that
investment
did i hear a dog in the background
we have a new
we have a new dog he's a rescue puppy
we've had him for two weeks and i'm
trying very hard
but he uh sometimes barks
what's the name
loki um and he's very sweet but he's a
bit barky
oh that's all right we love we love dogs
on this show you're obviously new to our
work he's welcome on the show whenever
it's good to talk to you thank you thank
you
thanks a lot